consider your predicament one skull two
tenants and no solution in sight I could
fix it all like laughs try to cure
yourself shop around beg borrow and
steal exhaust every possibility until
and
Pope has been whittled down to the very
marrow despair that's when you come
knocking
[Music]
[Music]
haha hi everybody and welcome to
community update number three for
baldur's gate three I have great news
today we finally locked down or early
access content and we decided that we're
gonna bring Wallis gate three for the
very first time in your hands in August
twenty twenty as to say maybe and the
maybe has everything to do of course
with Kovac nineteen we've been hit like
everybody else in the world we've been
working from home which wasn't
necessarily the easiest thing as game
developers because we like to huddle
around the monitor and discuss about the
things that are happening in the game
but nonetheless we managed to make a lot
of progress since you last saw the game
at PAX East so we think we're gonna make
it depending on a couple of things one
of these things for instance is our
performance capturing and motion
capturing or people have started to
return into the office we've been
recording again and if we can hit a
certain speed in the recording then we
should be able to make it the game is
looking amazing it is absolutely
incredible to see how much progress has
been made since PAX East and I think
when you'll see it you'll understand
what I'm talking about the visual
fidelity has increased a lot and the
cool part is that actually we're going
to launch a game in August in early
access but we still have an entire
development period to go after that so
it's going to look even better by the
time it's going to release you will see
things like improvement in combat we did
a lot of changes and how combat flows
how the camera moves how the initiative
system works all together they make for
a much more refined combat experience
which is a lot of fun I can tell you
that there are changes in the way that
we do or narrator that was something
that we had a lot of feedback on there's
the integration of the ruleset is
getting better and better so we were
getting a really good handle on how to
do things and so it feels like a really
really cool game with a lot of depth
when you play now here's the really cool
part you don't have to wait until August
22 22 see what I'm talking about because
we'll do another gameplay livestream and
we'll do it just in front of Dungeons &
Dragons live on June 18th and you will
decide for me
whether or not I'm going to kill a
Hobgoblin who deserves to be killed his
name is Dror axon or if i'm going to
descend into the Underdark i'm very much
looking forward to it so i hope to see
you there on June 18 it's gonna be a lot
of fun take care bye bye
what makes a true RPG
[Music]